the u.s is preparing for a presidential
transition like no
other in history after inciting the
violent storming of congress donald
trump now says that he will break with
tradition
and stay away from his successor's
inauguration
it will be a sober ceremony for
president-elect biden next week
with security services on high alert
amidst warnings that right-wing groups
could be planning to repeat the angry
protests at the capitol
congress has responded by to the
storming by initiating a second
impeachment against trump
who has been banned by social media but
the outgoing president continues to
claim he is the rightful winner of the
election
and his supporters believe him our title
today
joe biden becomes u.s president but how
dangerous does donald trump remain
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to welcome our guests
marcus keim is foreign policy expert and
senior fellow at the swp
institute for international and security
affairs here in berlin
and he says trump might for now leave
the political stage
but his 74 million followers won't be
going away
and it's great to have with us jamie fly
he is a republican who is currently
working with the german marshall fund in
berlin
he says donald trump's ability to
threaten american democracy is fading
but his legacy will loom large over the
country for years to come
and sariah nelson is a freelance
journalist based here in berlin
she works uh with the or it
has the podcast common ground
and is a former correspondent for the
u.s public radio
npr she says barring conviction in the
u.s senate donald trump
will retain his hold on the republican
party
so our title asks how dangerous trump
will remain
let's begin with the present and the
immediate future soraya nelson
how great is the threat of violent
attacks in the coming days
i think it's very high i mean that's you
can see that with 20 000
national guard and other troops that are
basically deployed to the u.s capitol i
mean that's
what is it at this point uh five times
as many as you have in afghanistan which
is a much more dangerous place just to
give you some
some point of comparison so it's it's
very dangerous and certainly the
authorities there are reacting in that
way it's it's quite the lockdown in
washington from what i understand
uh people are having really hard time
getting back and forth going to work and
uh
obviously we saw yesterday at the
capitol how people
or we saw you know how people are having
a hard time getting into the capital at
all
unless they go through metal detectors
if they're even if they're members
jimmy fly you said in your opening
statement that trump's
ability to threaten u.s democracy is
fading but
just two days ago he held a rally
at the southern border of the united
states
once again denied responsibility for
fomenting that attack
at the capitol and portrayed himself as
the victim of a witch hunt
doesn't he thereby stoke the ongoing
anger
of his supporters and also their urge to
take violent revenge
i think there's some potential for that
given that he still
is not embracing the fact that joe biden
will be inaugurated as the next
president however if you look at his
statements including the video he put
out yesterday
uh he is singing a different tune
certainly than he was in the weeks
running up to january 6th
he actually is urging his people not to
be violent
he never even talked in those terms
prior to all of this the reasons for
that are unclear whether it's
his own personal interest and he's
trying to stave off conviction
but i don't think he is uh trying to
incite
the sort of frenzy that we saw on
january 6 at this point and honestly he
doesn't have the platform to amplify
that message even if he wanted to
and so i i think all in all we're in a
better place than we were on january 6th
the key question is you know what groups
are going to show up and will law
enforcement
and the intelligence community be better
prepared this time and indications are
that they will
but we have to see marcus cohen
authorities are now releasing new
findings
about the storming of the capital on
january
6. as a security expert would you say
that these
indicate that that was in fact a planned
intentional attack or was it rather
a spontaneous outburst by a mob that
essentially got out of control
i'm not sure but what seems sure to me
is that
actually we could expect some kind of
violence even earlier
i think we wouldn't be surprised if we
would have seen something
like political violence in the context
of the election process at the beginning
of
november actually i was expecting some
polling stations
being burning or something
being looted or something else so i
think nobody could predict what predict
what
what could happen and what would happen
at the capitol one week ago
but i clearly wouldn't be surprised
about the um
about the determination of these kind of
groups and therefore
i'm not sure if we if we should call it
the plan
or schedule or whatever but i think it
comes as no surprise given the political
polarization and deep division of the
u.s society
that there are some actors some groups
being determined
to to perpetrate violent acts against
democratic institutions soraya hasn't
the fbi indicated that there definitely
was
some measure of concerted action here we
have some
very heavily armed individuals who moved
toward the capital who came from far
away
so clearly with intent we also
have some indications of very lack
security at the capitol and today
even reports that apparently uh there
were
abnormally high visitor numbers on the
day before
january 6th indicating perhaps that
people were
casing the joint and some allegations in
fact that's
certain republican congressmen who have
not been named at least
as of as of this morning who are giving
tours to people sort of reconnaissance
tours if you will to people who were
then
said to have been involved in the
attacks on saturday on on the following
day on wednesday
so it's it's very disturbing i mean it
does seem that there was some
forethought and some planning that went
into it
and it's something that i don't think
will go away i mean i i
as mentioned i mean i think there are a
lot of very angry people out there
on on that side in particular and right
now i'm sure that the anger is being
stoked by the fact that the president
is stepping back from being fully
supportive of what was going on he's no
longer saying i love you
you know he's now saying i don't condone
violence
um but it's important to note that this
is not necessarily an orchestrated
that everything is not necessarily
orchestrated because look at what's
happening at the airports when
congressmen are being approached by
individuals
who are getting in their face i mean
they're all these videos that are being
posted now
about that sort of aggressive mitt
romney for example
flying into washington and being called
a traitor by people who are on the plane
or even
more recently was i think congressman
correa from uh
from california who was accosted at
dulles international airport just a few
days ago jamie fry soraya just mentioned
it
there are indications that uh several
state congressional representatives of
state parliaments but
also possibly two members of the house
of representatives the federal
uh uh congress were taking part
in this uh invasion of the capital
for you as a republican how does that
make you feel
oh it's it's obviously disgraceful for
the republican party but this is the
problem uh after
four years of donald trump he has
brought the fringe
basically into the mainstream of the
republican party you now have republican
members of congress who
were elected as open supporters of the
conspiracy theory q anon
and to the credit of house republican
leadership they initially tried to
to uh defeat these people in primaries
but when they still won the primaries
the house leadership people like kevin
mccarthy steve scalise
embraced them and said we'll welcome you
as a normal member
and so yes you have people inside the
capitol members of congress
who uh are very much uh in line i think
ideologically with some of the
angry mob that was uh you know tearing
down the windows and doors of the
capitol and so it's a it's a frightening
development i think even for the ability
of congress as an institution to move
forward
when you have so much distrust within
the body itself
and you even had members on the
democratic side accusing
republican members of live tweeting the
location of nancy pelosi
during the riot uh and when you're at
that level when you don't even trust
your fellow lawmaker i think it's very
difficult to unite the country and to
actually move forward together
let's take a closer look at the
followers who took up trump's call to
march on the capitol
incited by donald trump's accusations of
election fraud
his supporters blaze a trail of
destruction through the capital
the insurrection is hitting american
democracy right in the heart
and in doing so the rioters believe that
they are well within their rights
we were normal good law-abiding citizens
and you guys did this to us
we want our country back we are
protesting for our freedom right now
facebook and twitter since suspended
donald trump's accounts
so he can't continue to incite more
violence
but he and his supporters are here to
stay
donald trump has already announced that
he will open his own media channel
today is not the end it's just the
beginning
[Applause]
but just how much of a danger do donald
trump and his supporters pose to the
next u.s president
joe biden
normal good law citizens marcus kaim if
you see those pictures
uh at least to many people abroad they
look a lot like a putch
i won't call it a put because nobody
really intended to
um to to fight for the political power
to
take back our country isn't that code
language for
essentially uh not handing over power to
the democrats
i'm not sure but um i think what has
been revealed
by the pictures is that there's a huge
disrespect for democratic institutions
a huge disrupt disrespect for democratic
procedures
and a huge disrespect for the political
opponent which in german terms
is the political opponent but in u.s
terms has become actually the enemy
which has to be excluded out from the
political discourse
and this is not the u.s specific i think
you can make the same argument that
political groups here in germany
reflect on the same reflections or
represent the same
ideas but this is the really frightening
and concerning
issue here that regardless of the
specific
institutional affiliation or the
specific group they belong to they're
united by this
united bond of disrespect and this
disrespect for the media could be added
as well um
this united bond of united by this point
of disrespect and
my concern is that won't go away for the
foreseeable future
certainly sariah nelson president trump
did a great deal to stoke
those resentments with language
that took political discourse in in
a new direction over the past four years
social media platforms
have now decided to bar him after doing
a lot to enable him over the last four
years
do you think that's necessary and right
or is there a risk that this will only
reinforce the myth of his martyrdom
i think uh the latter i think that uh at
least
in the in the initial stages here and it
depends on who else is silenced i mean
because certainly his son and other you
know his supporters
are talking about the fact that he has
been censored and that this is
wrong and that he's you know freedom is
is is now gone
and and these are all very insightful
sort of comments and approaches that i
think are just going to
fan those flames and reinforce the
notion as as marcus mentioned
that there is an enemy rather than a
political opponent
you seem to take a different view on
that uh jamie fry you said
a moment ago that uh barring him from
social media would significantly
decrease his influence
i think that in his particular case he
obviously violated
the terms of service of these platforms
on so many occasions i think the
companies actually should have acted
much a long time ago and not just with
him
i mean i think the danger is where this
is headed is i don't know that the
private companies
have the capabilities or are the people
that we should have policing our speech
and so we have a fundamental problem in
democracies
especially in the united states where
there hasn't been significant regulation
and now the fact that he and other
conservatives are starting to get their
accounts shut down it is
increasing this sense of victimhood and
the term for it on the right is cancel
culture
and so i don't think we found the right
approach i do think in this
interim period it was the right thing to
remove his platform because i think he
could have done a lot more damage in the
run-up to the inauguration
but the companies ultimately need and
working with the government need to come
up with a better solution
and it's not just donald trump honestly
the more concerning thing are the
far right and far left groups the
extremists the q anon conspiracy
theorists
and the companies also were very slow to
tackle the rise
of those groups online and the way that
those groups used their platforms for
organizing the very sort of gathering
that occurred on january 6th
we could clearly devote the rest of the
show and many others to the role of
social media but let me take us on to
the
newly inaugurated impeachment
proceedings uh the second
impeachment proceedings against donald
trump
mitch mcconnell the who is still the
senate majority leader that will change
uh
after next week but he says that uh
he also uh thinks impeachment actually
might be a way
to separate the republican party
essentially
from donald trump as a harmful influence
going forward
do you think that's right i think it's
potentially
right just because of the technicalities
of it it at least opens a path towards
donald trump being barred
from running for federal office i think
there's some constitutional questions
that will probably have to get resolved
if that
if conviction does occur in the senate
that may lead
more senators to be willing to convict
than was the case a year ago in the
previous impeachment
but i think especially given the the
limited showing of republicans that we
saw
yesterday only 10 in the house vote for
impeachment
it's not at all a foregone conclusion
that there will be enough senators
republican senators who are willing to
convict
this president he remains largely
popular even after
the events of january 6 and a lot of his
voters
i think are very likely to turn on
politicians in the republican party
who vote to convict him and especially
if it involves barring him from federal
office in the future
let's drill a little bit deeper on that
marcus kime
for anybody who did watch that
congressional debate
yesterday it was striking how many
republicans continued to justify donald
trump's
unconstitutional actions by essentially
pointing at the
finger at the democrats and listing all
the alleged wrongs
they had committed why do so
many stick by this man
i think claim we made exactly the point
the the right point
we are already approaching the next
election
the midterm elections and the experience
of the last four years told us
that every republican who is distancing
him or herself from the
from donald trump um becomes the the
target of some kind of political revenge
um
inside the by the republicans and in
particular by the president so
even with even with donald trump
about to lose power in the foreseeable
future i think he
remains a pivotal player in the
political scene and everybody
at least in the in the republican party
maybe not everybody but a lot of people
in the political party party are simply
afraid of him
and that explains that maybe silently
they would vote differently
or would have voted differently
yesterday but they cannot express
publicly on the other hand soraya in
america politicians need not only voters
but also donors
lots of money and we are seeing
increasingly important business
interests distancing themselves
from donald trump uh including the banks
that have loaned him money
over many many years what impact could
that have
on the republican party and trumpism
going forward
i think that would have the most impact
out of everything that we've talked
about but you have to look at the
language that these businesses are
are stating when they say that they're
pulling back it's temporary i mean there
are very few have said we're absolutely
not going to donate to him we're
absolutely not going to donate to
republicans
even like the amounts for example uh
that were given to holly you know one
thousand here one thousand there it's
not
there's a question about whether this is
something that's really uh that they
plan to sustain
or but it but it definitely has gotten
the republican attention having said all
that
i think in the end 74 million voters you
know 74.2 million voters voted for
donald trump
you cannot discount this i mean he
received
even though the gop has lost the seven
out uh seven out of the last eight
uh you know popular vote uh when you
look at the election seven out of eight
of them
it doesn't matter i mean this is a large
number of people
and they are they even after what
happened on january 6
most of them still remain loyal to
donald trump and the people who you see
leaving the gop or
you know they're all people who are more
moderate or basically traditional gop
is is what's going away there are not i
mean i haven't heard or read about
really anybody who is a maga person who
has you know i don't know felt what
happened on the six was so bad that
they should abandon donald trump jimmy
could
the republican party win the popular
majority if it alienates a large segment
of the trump voters
i think honestly because of the
demographic changes underway in the u.s
it's highly unlikely the republican
party will be able to win the popular
vote in a presidential election any time
soon
uh their hope is the electoral college
and i think many
feared that donald trump was actually
compromising that potentially
in recent months given his legal
campaign
related to the state legislatures and
issues like that
um so honestly that's the conundrum
they're in uh
74.2 million votes was an incredible
success for donald trump compared to the
expectations he actually
increased minority support for
republicans which no one
expected and so the talk after november
was about the republican party
becoming a multi-racial working-class
party
taking the working class away from the
democratic party
that is probably more difficult now
after january 6th
and a very white mob essentially
that seemed to have a racial agenda in
many cases well and donald trump
repeatedly playing the racist card
yes but again he drew more
african-american men to the republican
party in that election hispanics
uh and so some of the more moderate
figures in the party my old boss marco
rubio
governor nikki haley i think their hope
was then to take
what donald trump did to bring more
working-class voters and to
kind of soften the edges i think that
becomes again much more difficult given
what we've seen over the last week
but that was their hope uh and we'll
have to see whether donald trump is able
to be
an organized political force in
republican politics once he leaves
office
soraya super quick question because i do
want to take a look at what all this
means for biden and harris but
let's say that trump going forward did
split away from the republican party and
found his own independent movement and
that somehow he got enough money
to also create the media empire that our
report mentioned
would such a movement be able to win
again a majority popular election in the
united states
historically it all it doesn't seem to
be the case i mean look at ross perot he
didn't go very far with it either i i
have a hard time imagining
that that he would be successful in
doing that and i think creating this
media empire that he wants to create
that's going to require money that he
doesn't necessarily have right now
so um i'm i'm cautiously optimistic that
he won't do that that he will
try to stick with the republicans and
that this is going to cause
great uh issues for that party um i
don't think it's going to come together
soon so beyond the political
polarization that we've been discussing
the incoming democratic team faces a
pandemic that continues to rage across
much of america
and is exacting a painful human and
economic toll
our joe biden and kamala harris up to
the challenges that they face
joe biden and kamala harris this duo
will steer the fate of the u.s
for the next four years the stage is set
for the incoming u.s
president and his second in command
after also winning the runoff in georgia
democrats have a razor thin majority in
the house of representatives
and the senate for the first time in a
very long time
u.s vice president kamala harris will be
the deciding vote that will also allow
democrats to push their agenda through
the legislature in the future
giving them some much needed breathing
room for example
when appointing supreme court judges in
the future
or on new spending proposals for
coronavirus
the environment and socioeconomic
policies
all proposals that republicans are
likely to block there may be only a
short window of opportunity to pass
important legislation
the midterm elections are coming up next
year by then the razor thin democratic
majority could be gone
how much of the democratic agenda can
biden harris really get passed
breaking windows so let me ask all three
of you
joe biden has repeatedly promised to be
the president of all americans to heal
the divisions marcus kim you said in
your opening statement
he must find ways to appeal to the trump
voters how what are the first things he
needs to do one two three in his first
hundred days
i think the first the first task is
pretty obvious cope with the
consequences of the kovid crisis
and the second one i would recommend
something not to do
not to reverse the tax reform of the
trump
trump administration because that
brought so many people into
into labor in particularly the low
income
low in low income class
and and given the public opinion polls
of february
of march before the compete crisis it
becomes obvious
that the economic success of the trump
administration
was crucial for his endurance and and
for the
for the success of the trump
administration and here i would
i would be very cautious simply to
reverse what has been accomplished over
the last year
jimmy fry what would you say what are
the absolute top priorities for the
incoming administration if they're
serious about healing the division
i think the big i really think it's one
and for me coming from a republican
perspective is to avoid the progressive
impulse
uh i mean nancy pelosi has the smallest
house
majority i think since after the second
world war
a 50-50 senate despite the fact that
they have the vice president who can
break ties
is not really control of the senate uh
when the wait
unless you remove the filibuster which
would be incredibly damaging i think
the ability of the country to move
forward and i think joe biden
understands that given his
you know his general approach to
politics but he's going to be getting
prodded by the left of his party and
he's going to need to realize that he's
president for four years
and he can ignore those calls for now
while he tries to bring the country
together
soraya well if he's really desperate i
mean if things aren't getting better
then pardon trump i mean take that take
that wind away
you know not make that man look like a
martyr i mean that's something that he
may have to actually consider
um i can't believe i'm saying that a day
after he's been impeached but you know
how about the economic policy that biden
has promised to really give
the middle class relief to bolster good
jobs good wages and so on
will that reach the disinfected trump
voters well he has to make sure it does
i mean he has to win back that workers
party because as jamie mentioned the
republicans have become you know or the
gop has become the workers
party which which is not traditionally
what has been the case
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us today and thanks to you
out there for tuning in
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you